and miami will want to go quick enough
that they can play straight up defense
that's right with a two-for-one
opportunity
butler patiently massaging his way down
robinson gives it up back to butler a
three
no back tap ariza gives it up
to draggage out of three to tie it at
107.
and now milwaukee with the shot clock
turned off can hold for a potential
game-winner
crowd rising to its feet
middleton five seconds left in overtime
middleton with two
middleton he got it
with point five to go chris middleton
puts the bucks up two here in game one
that was a big time professional
move by a player who's been playing all
day
with great confidence 27 points just
watch now
as he creates the space right there he
got to his spot
and once he elevated the defender goes
right by him
see robinson tries to pick up here right
there there's the fade
not only does he elevate but he gets the
fade and he hits the bottom of the net
10 for 22 from the floor today and just
a great
offensive display by middleton chris
middleton
has the crowd going nuts outside
pfizer for him he told us late game
execution would be the key against miami
he felt better about his team's ability
to execute in close games late this year
compared to last postseason he just did
there but huby
miami with the basketball they can
advance it after the timeout down two
still plenty of time to catch and shoot
catch and shoot there's no doubt about
it
so they have that opportunity but let's
see what happens now
where the screens will come from they
don't have a chance now to throw the
ball and bounce
the guy to catch it and make another
play so it has to come
right off of the pass from the out out
of bounds
a key guy now is the passer raggage will
inbound
miami down 2.5 to go in overtime of game
one after middleton's
jumper put the bucks up
by two points
with giannis in front of him miami no
timeouts remaining
here's butler did he get it all that's
it game one belongs to the milwaukee
bucks
perseverance in overtime
and one final defensive stand
hands milwaukee an opening
win in this best of seven series
that was a great defensive play on
butler who came up
up the lane and made his move across to
in order to catch that pass but the
defender
right on top keep an eye on it right
here you see highlights right with him
now
hi excellent and he gets a piece of it
on the rise
just a terrific play and holiday has
been spectacular
at both ends of the floor here today not
just with the points
but